assassiné dans le Val-d'Oise dans mon
département où il habitait donc
effectivement c'était important d'avoir
cette au travail cette opération nous
dit il faut combattre un son discours
etc
quand on regarde au jeu la situation je
crois que mal avait elle avait devant
elle deux options la première option
c'est d'être un ministre et de dire en
tant que ministre je porte la
responsabilité de ce que faisait mon
cabinet qui
ce qu'on fait du cabinet savent qu'on
reporte au ministre c'est une vue
d'esprit sinon donc elle dit bah mon
cabinet j'assume mon cabinet j'assume ce
que fait l'administration et donc je
porte politiquement en projet j'en
assume les conséquences c'est la
première option qu'elle avait à la fin
de choix d'apparaître comme un
conséquent pas sérieux voilà mais le
point de départ c'est quand vous faites
des coups politiques puisque ce que vous
évoquez être justement c'est que comme
elle veut faire un coup politique un
inventé un truc peut-être une bonne idée
au départ et puis après ça devient
coupotique mal fait mal ficelé
de ce qu'on comprend certains de
certains ont été appelés par son cabinet
ou par elle-même il y a eu des échanges
préalablement enfin tout ça ces
documenté à la fois par les médias mais
également par rapport que vous étiez
donc elle avait ces deux options là donc
elle préfère inventer une vérité qui est
dire j'ai lancé le truc puis après moi
j'étais pas là donc on a le sentiment
qu'en fait Marlène Chapa n'a jamais été
vraiment ministre par contre mais ce qui
est assez intéressant c'est quand on
prend à porterie les déclars les
déclarations qu'elle faisait les windes
conférences de presse de lancement il y
a eu un centre d'articles dans la presse
ou à donner le sentiment de prendre ça à
bras le corps donc voilà donc elle fait
le choix d'inventer notre vérité qui
malheureusement n'est pas une vérité
pour pas utiliser d'autres termes et je
crois que ce qu'on voit devant nous
c'est un crash c'est très honnêtement le
crash d'une ministre qui après avoir
fait des coups après des coups elle est
rattrapée par la patrouille comme dirait
l'autre et elle vient de se scratcher je
crois devant l'ensemble des médias
puisque aujourd'hui le sentiment c'est
soit le ment parce que quand vous
écoutez effectivement les autres
intervenants notamment sur dirt ok mais
soit allemand soit elle était totalement
inconséquente et pas sérieuse donc je
suis chacun choisira en tout cas elle
fait choix de la légèreté plutôt que de
la responsabilité
[Musique]